miranda lambert yeah campaign to get
carrion to it the Entertainer of the
Year award at tomorrow night's CMA
Awards got Carey choked up so first
here's what Miranda said the Carey's
reaction on the Ty Bentley Show I'm a
huge fan of everyone in the category
huge fan but if you think about someone
who hosted the CMAs pregnant and then
started an all-female tour and then had
a baby and they went right back on the
road three months later she has a brand
her Kelly about Carrie Underwood and it
lifts up women she does Monday Night
Football and I just feel like as a whole
Entertainer of the Year should be
someone that entertains in all facets of
music and she has nine million followers
on social media and she really engages
with her fans and I feel like that to me
is my entertainment of the year male or
female she works harder than I do and I
work hard and I just felt like as a
whole with her tour and everything she
encompasses and what she's represented
for country music she deserves it she
just does I do you hear that I had not
was that cool
it's Miranda yeah it's really cool she's
always been just super supportive and
just super sweet mm-hmm I'm I'm kind of
emotional um I mean it it's it's it
would be it's a nomination for all of us
you know and it would definitely be you
know not not just a win for all of the
things that we've been doing all the all
that stuff that that she mentioned that
I'm so lucky and blessed enough to do
but I mean you know you watch other
women in this in this industry do the
same thing and you know it's it's I
don't know I don't know what I'm trying
to say other would not won Entertainer
of the Year before I don't think so
that's the wild part of this story to me
I think Carrie Underwood should be in
contention every year let's say that
entertainers or nominators I don't think
brain has ever been nominees that's
funny to see something like Carrie
Underwood like who still is like having
to put the
worked in it can get emotional like that
just kind of thinking how hard people
are working to try to get noticed in the
industry and like we were talking about
this for years like women in country
music I know what's going on but it's
still crazy that they're not getting
recognition but that's what look is
really Miranda and Carrie are the two
people that are get an insane amount of
tension in the same amount of airplay
that kind of thing so see like take our
DB and Nicki Minaj take a pager I know
you're like in fact like they're the
only two female rappers to get attention
so right why should they be at odds when
yeah Carrie and Miranda very supportive
of each other yeah it's it's it's it's
well and it's somebody who's not deep
into country right as an outsider of
that world where you dip into it every
now and then to interview it my
perception of country is that it's all
run by women that the women that the
women run that whole industry because
the biggest stars to me my perception of
country music are all the female stars
yeah I guess yeah you don't hear as much
about like the Jason Aldean's in terms
of I guess nominated but in terms of
know like people that actually radio
it's all guys yeah in the sport that's
wild Josef's last person that won in
2011 really yes Wow okay coming up Nia
takane alive Drake its booed off stage
first no one will be booing this trio on
stage Wednesday night when Carrie Reba
and Dolly co-host the CMA Awards and
they are in their final prep for the big
show looking around at all of the like
talent and amazing women gorgeous smart
talented women like bunnies lots of gigs
up there as a big night for all of us
and we're just trying to earn back
getting the right clothes and
coordinating our makeup
and all the girly things see that's the
trouble with doing the show with all
girls you wouldn't believe the chaos
backstage it is funny and they're trying
to put more rhinestones on my plane more
can't get too many rhinestones black
spark I never met around so I didn't
like